listen we got to settle something yeah a
couple episodes ago you really lit into
us for drinking
uh drinks with ice in them yes
refreshing drinks yeah and you said you
would buy us straws
you never did well first of all i'm a
busy man okay you know that's fine
straws are very hard to find
well i've got some here oh
i do want to help the environment so we
don't want to have uh disposable straws
what'd you get these are just you know
just uh
multi-use metallic straws
and they're a little warm because
they're in my pocket but don't worry
oh god you sure know how to excite a
fella and oh i'm sorry i called you
pervy
would you like a lap temperature straw
can we bring david in david has gotten
us some some of the very same icy drinks
that we were getting last time oh hi
here's david hopping who is the very
very good
um assistant who's been filling in okay
you don't have to personally stretch out
he just i call him david picks up on the
first ring hopping okay um and um oh
this is incredible so you brought david
you you brought the same drinks yes
so we can see so go ahead and start
talking and sona and i will try okay so
just say something important
okay
i've got a very important announcement
here
from
are we submerging are we taking the sub
down
dive dive what do you do what is this
experiment supposed to tell me you freak
you're not you're
no one sips like this and and yours is
all going into your lungs clearly girly
you're like
let me give me one of these groin straws
which i will now call them
look
i've got one and i think hold on a sec
this is just me now you stopped sona you
stopped and coffee you stopped too okay
i laughed when i drank it
you were like let's let's test your
straws
i will pour the liquid into my lungs and
we'll see how quiet it is i was so
excited to do this bit i started
laughing before it was funny okay let's
hold on let's let's let me let me try it
and let's really this is just me you
guys back away from yours let me let's
see this is me i'm holding it right up
to the mic i'm talking let's say i'm
interviewing
jeff goldblum okay uh hello jeff oh okay
oh conan yes yes oh my boy my boy oh yes
oh jeff do you mind if i take a little
sip oh my oh my boy please please please
hydrate hydrate all you will yes
yes oh hydration i was in the fly
thank you jeff i appreciate it here we
go wow silent let me try that try it
oh stop doing that
what are you
idiots
conan you might yes jeff what is it well
they're clearly exaggerating me
for the sounds of their uh drinks
oh my boy oh listen to that
i love how you put a lot of thought into
this you had david go out and get straws
everything i brought this drug from home
in a warm
body temperature back
i do hope you're okay i've never seen
someone
there is no reason to make all that
noise i brought up my brother neil
because
his thing is
he loves to drink a soda but he puts a
ton of ice in it and anytime i call him
i mean anytime i call him
he's uh he's crunches the ice he says he
likes it because it makes the soda last
longer
and he's just crunching the ice the
whole time i'm talking to him i'll be
telling him something like
jesus come on girly sorry
i'm trying to now you
sorry
that's just what people want to hear
during a
two-year covid crisis
i cough a lot i clear my throat when i
laugh well screw what i was saying
no your brother crunches ice and i think
that's why you hate it so much because
you want your people's undivided
attention and you think they're
distracted and i'll be telling neal
something like yeah you know i haven't
confessed this to anyone before but i've
got a real fear of crunch crunch
crunch crunch the whole time
and i'm like i can't talk to her like
you know i've always felt like what i
should really want to say to our father
is crunch crunch crunch crunch crunch
and now i'm doing nixon crunching ice oh
crunch a crunch crunch
mr president uh we really think
watergate's getting out of here crunch
crunch
crunch
mr president i know you uh are done with
your soda can i just take the no no no
there's still i should have but go ahead
what did you have to say
well anyway they've revealed that there
are tapes crunch crunch
crunch crunch crunch crunch cuts crunch
crunch crunch do you think this is going
to follow me around these tapes well
we're really worried about crunch crunch
crunch
stain crunch or does nixon eating ice
cream
crunchy when nixon does anything the
sound effect is in his voice okay so if
nixon's like well
time to cross the room
walk walk
walk
this is like nixon sound effects theater
it is it needs a sound to take cedar and
now i'm going to enjoy this uh icy drink
crunch crunch crunch crunch crunch uh
because of the ice
he explains he explains the sounds that
was uh terrible your whole experiment
was a failure but we had some good
laughs we had fun getting there didn't
we
oh my god
well why don't you go have a tracheotomy
okay and that'll open an airway i need
help yeah and um
very good